hello from florida i'm dave rubin this
is the reuben report direct message it
is january 11 20 22
and life is good here in the sunshine
state if you missed the show yesterday
and you're wondering what i'm doing sort
of behind my old background we are
taping this week here at newsmax studios
in boca raton
as we build out our temporary studios at
my new house which we're moving into
this week and then ultimately we will be
building out permanent studios at my
house we're going to be temporary for
about a month then the full-time
awesome studios going forward after that
but the newsmax people were nice enough
to let us use the studio here so i thank
them for that oh and one other
housekeeping thing
starting next week we will be back
to our normal schedule with a slight
adjustment instead of 11 a.m pacific 2
p.m eastern
we will now be live every day at 11 a.m
eastern so adjust your calendars your
satellites move your children's
activities your job
whatever you got to do to make sure that
you're watching the show
next monday live five days a week at 11
a.m
eastern and this week uh we're just sort
of going up whenever we can because
there's a lot going on here and i
appreciate your patience and all the
well wishes people are very excited that
i'm in florida it's it's really
fantastic uh all right before we get to
the stories today i wanted to quickly
mention that speaking of florida god
it's so much nicer talking about florida
than talking about california
today in about an hour from when we're
taping this
ron desantis governor ron desantis is
giving his state of the state address
you all know about the state of the
union address this is every january when
the president of the united states gives
his usually about an hour and a half
speech about
what his administration wants to do the
sort of state of the world what our
policies are going to be
you know really the president's vision
of what the country is people don't know
this but governors also give a state of
the union they give a state of the state
ron desantis is doing his as i said in
about an hour from now and we are going
to try to grab some clips later uh and
put some stuff up because to me it seems
like if florida succeeds then america
succeeds and then maybe the world
succeeds right maybe we get this thing
back maybe we reverse the insanity so i
want to treat ron desantis's state of
the state of florida as if it was the
state of the union because joe biden can
give us a state of the union but it's
like is that the guy you want leading us
going forward are those the ideas going
forward the people who've gotten
everything wrong i mean everyone
realizes how much worse everything is
the guy's only been president for a year
doesn't it feel like a lifetime already
so i want to treat the state of the
state of florida as if it was the state
of the union so we will
be covering that and i'm sure you'll see
a whole bunch of clips on that but i
know having uh i can't say what we
talked about at our off the record
dinner but i know he has a he has a
great vision for this state which is a
which is a way of modeling a great
vision for the country uh and speaking
of ron desantis real quick uh they have
just released from ron desantis's
official website they have just re
released the escape to florida the
lockdown lib tour t-shirts because as we
covered yesterday aoc has been down here
for vacation and swalwell and the rest
of these guys so on the back of the
shirt
it's got some of the politicians who are
vacationing in florida while they lock
down their own people and crush the
economy and destroy lives and all the
rest of it so governor whitmer from
michigan's on there she vacationed in
west palm beach uh eric swalwell that
farting freak who also slept with the
chinese spy yes that's true uh he was in
miami beach a couple days ago don lemon
from the network uh the comedy network
cnn uh he was vacationing in palm beach
a couple weeks ago and aoc and of course
her boyfriend's feet they were in miami
beach so you can get that shirt if you
want to jump on the ron desantis website
i get nothing for that i just felt it
was kind of funny i guess we'll get some
for the team and go from there anyway uh
we got a couple stories to cover for you
today we're going to mix it up a bit got
to do a bunch of covid stuff but you
know my policy
on the coveted stuff which is basically
like let's talk about the good news
related to covid well it seems like the
narrative is just completely collapsing
we realize that lockdowns don't work now
they're admitting that the masks mostly
don't work and now they're kind of
admitting that the vaccines don't really
work it's like everything that they have
told us for the last two years is just
coming out to be either either untrue or
intentionally misleading or
some cacophony of complete incompetence
so to me that's good news because sanity
maybe is getting the day maybe these
people who have suffered from mass
formation psychosis are gonna start to
wake up you of course watching this has
not suffered from that and i applaud you
for that uh so we'll do some covid stuff
then there's this crazy lady uh who sort
of looks like an alien this nancy pelosi
and she's going on and on about how
republicans are trying to steal
elections and it's really just her
projecting what she and the democrats
are trying to do you know you move in
illegals you let them vote you don't
have to show id's to vote et cetera et
cetera and i wanted really to show you
this uh video not necessarily because of
that specifically but
the woman has just had another facelift
or they did something to her eyebrows
and it looks like the alien is about to
burst forth right out of her mouth so
we'll uh we'll talk about that uh and
then finally i thought this one was
interesting relative to me moving to
florida and everything else
meta which is
facebook's new name and they want to put
us on this metaverse you know we're
gonna wear vr headsets and we're gonna
do all our shopping and all of our
interpersonal communication will be done
in this digital world which perhaps
that's why they're trying to destroy the
real world with lockdowns and everything
else so they can push us into this thing
where they can control us more
conspiracy theorists
well meta the offices are moving to
austin texas and i thought that was
interesting because it's like all right
it's good if things move to free states
but only if the people that are moving
there are going to defend those free
states and i sense that this one because
facebook is so infected with leftist
lunacy this is probably not a great
thing for texas certainly not for austin
so we'll get to all of that and before i
do speaking of states let's talk about
the convention of states for just a
moment you know there's no question in
my mind that vaccine mandates are
unconstitutional overreach if you're a
regular viewer or listener to my show
you probably agree with me the question
is what are we going to do about it you
can keep complaining that does work for
a lot of people all the time
or we can keep voting for quote-unquote
better federal politicians but we've
tried that and news flash it doesn't
really work we need a better solution to
federal overreach and my buddy mark
meckler has one article 5 of the
constitution allows the states to call a
convention of states this isn't about
politics this is about real solutions at
this convention the states gather to
propose constitutional amendments that
take away everything career politicians
love their money their power and their
careers in office the best part there's
not a single thing that the feds can do
to stop us this movement is supported by
names you know like glenn beck governor
ron desantis and mark lemin go to
convention estates.com dave today and
sign the petition to demand that your
legislators vote yes to convention
estates i encourage you to stop
complaining and do something visit
conventionofstates.com
dave and sign the petition convention
estates.com dave and now back to me all
right let's talk a little bit about
misinformation and mass formation
psychosis and people who have lied to us
all along and who are now
finally getting called out on it so
peter ducey who works at fox news you
know him he is basically the only one in
the white house press corps during jen
saki's ridiculous theater shows that she
does every day she's really the only one
who asks any sort of grilling sort of
pointed question to saki you know my
feelings about sake and yesterday he
really asked a great question about how
he's been vac saki's been vac people are
still getting covered what's going on
here jen
i understand that the science says that
vaccines prevent
death
but
on triple backs still got covet your
triple backs still got cobit why is the
president still referring to this as a
pandemic of the unvaccinated well i i
think peter there's a significant
difference between and you just you just
experienced this and not to expose your
public health experience but i can speak
to mine as well i had been triple vaxxed
i had minor symptoms there is a huge
difference between that and being
unvaccinated you are 17 times more
likely to go to the hospital if you're
not vaccinated 20 times more likely to
die and those are significant serious
statistics
so yes the impact uh for people who are
unvaccinated is far more dire than those
who are vaccinated will the president
update his language at some time to be
more reflective of the fact that people
who are triple vaccinated are catching
and spreading covenant i think people
president has said as have we a number
of times that there will be breakthrough
cases there will be people who get covid
uh here uh at different media
organizations at companies around the
world uh around the country uh who have
been vaccinated okay so let's be 100
percent clear here
joe biden said you are not going to get
covered if you have these vaccinations
the the various
shots that people are getting now cover
that they're they're you're okay you're
not gonna you're not gonna get covet if
you have these vaccinations yeah so
either joe biden was lying
or joe biden did not know or they handed
him a piece of paper and he just reads
off the teleprompter and all that or
someone from pfizer was lying or one of
someone in his administration was lying
or one of the health professionals or
scientists somebody was lying or
manipulating the truth or they got
everything wrong i'm not even going to
attack their their motives at the moment
but we now know that what joe biden said
there was untrue so
if we are to believe that we are still
in the midst of this horrific pandemic
and by the way a lot of people are
getting omicron and there was the whole
christmas wave and i got it too and i
know plenty of people that got it
everyone that i know got it
survived
but if we're to believe that we're still
in the midst of this thing why hasn't
anyone been fired why hasn't anyone why
isn't congress pulling the heads of
pfizer and these other companies and
putting them on the stand and making
them testify under oath as to what
happened whether whether the vaccines
actually work as promised or not why
isn't anyone saying joe
maybe you lied or you didn't know what
was going on or whatever else i also
want to address what saki is saying
there
because she basically is like yeah i'm
triple vaxxed and i got coveted and i
had mild symptoms well i'm not vaxxed i
got kovid two and a half weeks ago and i
had some leg aches and i did have a sore
throat for one day and i took some
ricola and i took the ivermectin it
didn't turn me into a horse although i
did have a desire to have some sugar
cubes and here i am i survived i made it
so what right do you have gensake you
decided to get yourself triple
vaccinated you still got kovid
i didn't and i still got covered i now
have natural immunity what right do you
have to mandate that i do the thing that
you did when we had the same result you
have no right that actually is the point
but anyway it's just an endless cascade
of these people now being exposed as
frauds and liars and people that wanted
to control your life with no right to do
so here is the pfizer ceo albert borla
saying that two doses offer very limited
protection if any this is quite bizarre
considering what i just showed you joe
biden said uh and we know that um the
three the two dose of a vaccine offer
very limited protection if any the three
doses with a booster
they offer reasonable protection against
hospitalization and deaths
in getting there's nothing very good
and
less protection against the infection
now we are working on
a new version of our vaccine the 1.1 let
me put it that way that will cover
omitron as well
and
of course
we are waiting to have the final results
the vaccine will be ready in march two
doses offer very limited protection but
wait a minute wait a minute i remember
when i just played three minutes ago
didn't joe biden say something else
the the various
shots that people are getting now cover
that they're they're you're okay you're
not gonna you're not gonna get covet if
you have these vaccinations yeah okay so
again they're not giving you what they
promised and uh whether that's lying
maliciously whether biden doesn't know
what the hell he's doing whether this
all has nothing to do with covet and
it's much more about controlling your
life
where am i alex jones uh now we've got
some video this is cdc director rochelle
wilinski
and you're not going to believe it
people they've been counting covet
deaths that perhaps had nothing to do
with covet
the overwhelming number of deaths over
75 percent occurred in people who had at
least four comorbidities so really these
are people who were unwell to begin with
uh
what
four comorbidities
four comorbidities four other things
that might have killed these people
maybe they got hit by a truck fell off a
building got caught in the gears of a
combine
had uh you know bad headache what is
going on here
why are these people not being hauled in
front of congress why are these
i don't like throwing people in the
gulags but we're gonna have to start
talking about it these people have lied
about
absolutely everything the vaccines work
no the vaccines don't work uh
lockdowns work no lock downs don't work
masks work no masks don't work
i don't like these people very much do
you like these people and also let's
remember that uh the ceo of pfizer and
the head of the cdc they don't have any
real control over you unless you give
them that control the one is the head of
a of a pharmaceutical company those used
to be the bad guys right like
pharmaceutical companies used to be bad
guys five years ago that's what
mainstream would have told you they just
want profits and they want to inject you
with things and side effects and blah
blah now we can't ask about that and
this woman willenski from the cdc who's
gotten everything wrong all along and
was lying about masks and everything
else it's like she doesn't have any
authority over me i'm a free citizen in
a free state and she should be fired and
then hauled in front of congress and
have to explain why she lied about
everything and how connected she was to
people at the pharmaceutical companies
and who was making money off all of this
stuff and all the rest of that
all right let's move on to nancy pelosi
and nancy pelosi
lord nancy pelosi you know i left
california to escape people like nancy
pelosi but she still pops up on the
video machine uh here she is talking
about republicans those scary
republicans and january 6th
what the republicans are doing across
the country is really a a legislative
continue continuation of what they did
on january 6th which is to undermine
our democracy to
undermine the integrity of our elections
to
undermine the
uh
the voting power which is the essence of
a democracy okay before i get into the
substance of what she just said there
which was pure nonsense uh i hope that
connor you can put up a still image of
nancy pelosi from that video that we
just saw there so people can look at her
eyebrows what in god's name is happening
there that is not a human face
the alien is bursting forth i don't know
if that's a facelift or an eye lift or a
whatever i don't begrudge her her
ability to do whatever she wants but
these people are crazy and they're
starting to look crazy joe biden also
looks crazy from all the work the
tightening and the pulling and the hair
plugs and the dentures yeah why are we
governed by these geriatric buffoons but
now let's get to the to the substance of
what she said
of course a few days ago was the
anniversary of the january 6th
insurrection which is the most orgasmic
holiday that democrats and their media
cohorts will ever have and each year
they will
just jizz all over themselves as they
talk about it it's quite disgusting
sorry sorry michael um
uh but what she's saying there is oh
they tried to take over the government
with their insurrection on january 6 and
yeah sure nobody brought any weapons
they had no plans one guy maybe had a
lego set of the capital it turned out
that wasn't even true i'm not defending
anyone that broke the law you can't just
break windows and attack police officers
and everything else but there was a lot
of just like let's just walk in and see
what's what not even getting into any of
that nonsense it was done in three hours
aoc's life was never
under threat or anything else like that
but what she's saying is what they're
doing now is a legislative continuation
of what they did on january 6. so what
is it
nancy that republicans are doing with
these election bills well they're doing
things like ensuring that people have to
have ids to vote uh making sure that you
can't uh canvas right outside polling
stations making sure that mail-in
ballots are more secure making sure that
we don't change election laws right
before elections a whole bunch of really
same stuff unlike the story we covered
yesterday in new york city where they're
going to allow
800 000 people
000 people uh who have been in the
united states illegally for more than 30
days they're going to be allowed to vote
we're not going to check ids and the
rest of it so everything that they say
is a lie it's so weird right it really
is like a weird thing like what is that
are you human at some level if every day
you get up
publicly and you just lie about
everything she knows she's lying and by
the way this is this is where the media
always drops the ball because whoever
was interviewing her there it's like
look i'm an interviewer and everyone can
criticize
interviewers everyone has a different
style and everything else but it's like
an interviewer should follow up and be
like all right well what you're saying
there is you're claiming that the
republicans are trying an insurrection
via the legislative branch with these
laws that they're passing so what is it
about showing voter id uh that is so
evil right like what is it about making
sure that citizens only allowed to vote
that are so evil like they should be
pushed on these things and and they
rarely are
all that being said there's obviously an
alien somewhere in pelosi it could burst
forth from her stomach that's the
traditional way that aliens burst forth
uh but this alien seems to be bursting
forth from her face remember that scene
in uh
in men in black when the alien comes
down and it takes over the guy and he
wants sugar water or lemonade or
something right at the beginning and
he's pulling on his face that's what
she's starting to look like i think you
know what i'm talking about conor can we
get that image you know what i'm talking
about the guy he's pulling his face you
want sugar water
okay
all right we got one more for you today
so meta which is the new facebook as if
facebook wasn't horrible enough for the
last 20 years first off is anyone on
facebook anymore i mean i know we're on
facebook i suppose but i don't have
anything to do with it and i don't you
know you're getting on facebook
sometimes i'm sitting on a plane and
i'll see someone with an ipad like going
through their facebook feed and i
haven't seen it i haven't been on
facebook myself in so long it's so nuts
you look at people on their feet and
it's like picture of a baby terrorist
attack trump
bush
you know like it's just like so insane
video game this that like it really
could all make you nuts well a lot of
people i guess still are on facebook but
facebook realizes that they're losing
some steam so they've decided to rename
the company meta and they're trying to
push us all into this meta universe if
you don't know what this meta universe
is i would recommend that you watch
ready player one or you could read the
book ready player one they want us all
basically wearing vr helmets and living
in this digital world and perhaps that
is why they are destroying the physical
world and by the way the elites and all
of the people pushing this stuff they
won't have their kids doing it and
they'll continue to live in the real
world and have their yachts and all of
those things but they'll want you to do
it because what a great way to control
the masses just lock them into something
give them pleasure all the time make
sure you can control their finances i
mean it's just so obvious what's
happening right now it's crazy and yes
we are in a dystopian future and it's
happening right now well
meta the company meta they're moving to
austin texas we've got some info here
from the daily wire facebook's parent
company meta has become the latest
california corporation to at least
partly move to texas as it has signed a
massive lease called the largest ever
in downtown austin now i want to address
something quick
daily wire of course themselves left
california left los angeles to go to
nashville tennessee but now facebook
which you know it's been in silicon
valley forever and you know zuckerberg's
got billions living the good life in
reality and he's going to put you in
your little vr box
they're moving to texas now it's
interesting because austin is the blue
center of texas right texas is obviously
a red state although not as red as it
should be i mean ted cruz only beat beto
o'rourke the furry guy by like a point
and a half last time so texas isn't as
safe as it probably should be
although now there's some signs pointing
that it is getting a little stronger red
but putting that aside they're going to
go to austin and the issue here is that
they're going to bring in probably
thousands i don't know how many
employees they're going to bring in or
whether it's going to happen all at once
or what but they're going to probably
bring in thousands of people who have
all been infected by the woke virus like
how can you work at facebook at this
point with their diversity and inclusion
and all of the [ __ ] that we know they do
related to the algorithm and
misinformation and their fact checkers
and all of that stuff if you work there
you're basically voting the wrong way
you're controlling information you're
probably somewhat woke you're a new
neo-racist because you believe in
critical race theory and all that and of
course i don't mean every single
employee but in essence thousands of
those people
are now moving into austin and they will
make austin bluer and by the way austin
has a lot of homeless problems now and a
bunch a bunch of other stuff but then
potentially make texas bluer this is
this is dangerous stuff and if you think
that that isn't dangerous enough just
people moving there and then ruining
something that was good well here's a
little video
that walmart put up about what your
shopping experience will be like when
you're in the metaverse
great looks like you need a good wine
pairing take a look to your right
your age has already been pre-verified
through your profile so no need to wait
for an id check just place the item in
your cart whenever you're ready
looks like that's everything on your
list are you ready to check out with
walmart pay
i'll have the tv brought out to your car
thanks for shopping at walmart have a
great day
i just want to be very very clear i
don't want anything to do with meta i
get this is the new thing that the
system that the machines are going to be
pushing on us and do you get it about
the control part it's like oh you can
just sit in your room and you can go to
the milk section and you can go to the
electronics section and buy this buy
that and then a drone is going to bring
it to your house and maybe the drone
will you know fire a rocket at your kids
who knows or maybe uh if you've been a
bad person and perhaps you voted the
wrong way or didn't get vaccinated
perhaps walmart pay is not going to work
for you or you'll have to pay more for
certain things or as crazy as it sounds
could they maybe charge you more because
you're white
i mean these things i know it all sounds
nuts but the
this all of this awful [ __ ] hasn't
come to its final conclusion yet it
hasn't
done exactly what it's supposed to do
yet a lot of people think we're moving
past it and in certain places we are but
the machine
watch watch the matrix man the machine
finds a way of being in front of you and
uh
i don't want anything to do with that
i'm going to try to live in the real
world call me old school
you know what i'm saying
uh guys you can always play along get
videos early and get bonus content and
chat with me directly the only place now
that i communicate with people
is at reubenreport.locals.com i don't as
i said i don't run the facebook page but
i don't respond to people on twitter but
i do respond to dozens of comments every
single day at rubinreport.locals.com and
we're just growing out a great community
uh my next book don't burn this country
will be out in april we're working on
putting the tour together i want to be
very very very very very clear about
this i will not tour
in any theater that demands people wear
masks i don't care what you've been
injected with
so that probably will cost us a whole
bunch of money but i just think you have
to do what's right sometimes uh most of
the time probably would be best and uh
i'm doing a mini interview that we will
put up tomorrow with senator rand paul
who officially has left youtube he's not
just talking to the talk he's walking
the walk and he will be exclusively on
rumble i know a little bit about rumble
and i thought it would be worth talking
to the senator about that one more
reminder starting next monday we are
live every day at our new time which is
11 a.m eastern
and uh
that's it i'm feeling good thanks again
to the newsmax guys for hooking us up
and we'll see you guys tomorrow
you